competitive halo is back after being
gone for years and the first lan has
kicked off but it hasn't started without
any sort of drama precipitating it
what kind of drama well the cheating
kind a sentinel's halo player has been
suspended from play for over a month and
honestly the entire thing got kind of
messy
[Music]
all right y'all before we get into the
video i gotta remind you as always hit
the like button the subscribe button and
to ring the notification bell if you
don't
i can't show you my grunt impression
i've been working really hard on so in
case you've been living under a rock
halo infinite is out and a lot of people
are playing it first we had a surprise
multiplayer launch and then we've had
the campaign launch i did promise the
guys i would not make this video about
my thesis about how why cortona has had
the worst character development ever if
you guys want to see that let me know
down in the comment section below
because i have many thoughts
and slides but i digress competitive
halo is back and it's back in full force
sentinels beat optic gaming in the grand
finals of the north america hcs raleigh
qualifier after a bracket reset stopping
optic gaming from three-peating
sentinels have done the unthinkable from
losers bracket i know 12 they've managed
to win back to back to back to back to
back to become grand final champions and
they will be the number one seed bravo
going into rally sentinels would then go
on and win the esports arena 25k
invitational so we had the intensity we
had the drama
or at least we thought we had the drama
see this specific torrent was to
determine seating for halo infinite's
first lan event which just started so
sentinels won and we're the qualifying
champions with optic gaming as the
number two seed
but the story doesn't end there see the
gameplay was done but apparently
something was off remember this was
playing for seating for the first lan
tournament which means this was played
online
which means ping is involved and i'm not
going to explain to you what ping is
because our crack team did that already
for like 15 minutes so dimitri take it
away
what exactly is
ping ping is used to measure the latency
or amount of time it takes to send and
receive a packet of data between two
devices such as your computer and a
game's servers and most importantly ping
is measured in milliseconds so how does
ping relate to this story well allegedly
sentinels are being accused by other
teams of geo-filtering after the last
online tournament and a few days before
the online tournament a lot of teams got
together and accused sentinels of
cheating for three days straight before
the tournament and all throughout the
tournament every single server that
sentinels played on was a seattle server
so if you guys don't know there's a
thing called geofiltering which is a
basic way that you can block out any
server that gives you a ping over a
certain amount
and people are accusing royal two of
using a geofilter because he's from
saskatchewan canada snipe down new place
for phase made an entire video
explaining exactly what these
accusations entail using vods and trying
to show exactly what sentinels were
being accused of usually the way that
servers work in halo is that it averages
out the ping in the lobby so like if you
have four people from florida and four
people from california it should be like
a dallas server to make the ping as like
fair as possible that's usually how it
works so frosty is on 60 ping and you're
gonna notice like i have to flip through
the vod in this video of him going to
every round but anytime you see his
teammates in the game
you're going to notice that frosty is on
60 ping if you're confused that's okay a
tl dr is that a sentinel's player royal
2 was accused of geofiltering which
means he would get better ping because
he lived farther away from servers than
his teammates or other players basically
he's accused of forcing his matches onto
a specific server which not only
benefited him but created a disadvantage
for his opponents if you play valorent
like i do with friends across the
country you might have had these
conversations about hey are texas
servers okay or should we go to virginia
servers basically it's like that but
with competitive integrity involved
because
what might be good for one team might be
horrible for another so there was lots
of murmuring even allegations of royal
two deleting vods it was
messy basically sniped on said that
after the tournament the team was
confronted about geofiltering and royal
two went ahead and deleted his vods and
then it got messier on december 12 2021
we got a tweet from the official halo
championship series twitter that linked
to a statement that read following the
any kickoff qualifier 12 1 tournament on
december 1st and 2nd 2021 a number of
players raised allegations that
sentinels had forced the game to select
a server resulting in abnormally high
ping for players in the game lobby one
of these accusations was directed
towards royal two from sentinels so let
me scroll down a little bit and i want
you to buckle up because this is this is
a long one basically they discovered
while looking at royalty's logs that all
but one server were missing from the
quote server ping list forcing all of
royal two's matches onto that server and
creating abnormally high ping for
players in the affected matches they
later ran a replication using a known
geofiltering method and got the same
data signature as rail2 where only one
server would be available they also
claimed that sentinels had opportunities
to explain themselves and whatever they
provided to do so were inconsistent with
the quote timeline of data
irregularities and then we had our
ruling we have determined that the only
plausible explanation for royalty's
telemetry data pattern referred to above
is that there was a direct modification
of files giving royalty an unfair
competitive advantage during play then
we had the penalties royal two was
suspended until january 28 2022 and
sentinels lost their first full play
position for raleigh sentinels were
ruled to be able to compete in raleigh
but they would have to do so without
royal two and make their way through the
open bracket almost immediately there
was some confusion from sentinels and
then some more confusion frosty was
implying that the whole thing just
didn't make sense there were allegations
of an unfair judicial process from the
players lethal on twitter said that the
team would not be attending the
tournament as well as saying that they
found out about the ruling's details via
the tweet like everyone else later royal
2 posted his statement on twitter via
twitlonger he explained that quote
during the launch of halo infinite i was
experiencing extremely high paying with
the central server i changed my settings
to use the west coast server but failed
to turn it off for the any kickoff
qualifier while this was corrected
before last night's esports arena
tournament i understand the issues my
oversight caused for the qualifier i
truly did not realize the impact this
decision would have and for that i am
deeply sorry and apologize to my fans
and wish my teammates the best of luck
in raleigh so sentinels are competing in
raleigh in fact the person they brought
in to fill in their roster is from a
little organization known as optic
gaming is that ring a bell the team that
placed second to sentinels the one i
mentioned earlier so formal will be
taking royal to spot this weekend as
they feel for the sentinel's halo roster
he made it clear that he was still loyal
to optic gaming and said that this
weekend should be a spicy one this is a
really interesting move because formal
got his career started in halo and then
moved over to call of duty but then
retired from it now going into it we
have a lot of interesting things to
consider like how sentinels are going to
be climbing their way through the open
bracket which wasn't the plan like
imagine you're a team in the open
bracket and then all of a sudden
sentinels are your opponents whether or
not the cheating was on purpose only
royal two knows that it does bring up a
lot of interesting points about playing
esports during a pandemic obviously for
safety reasons we all can't constantly
get together so we go online but stories
like this are making people aware that
in the age of online competitive play
that there is a possibility that even
lag itself
can be used as a tool for cheating
before we get into the video i gotta
remind you as always to hit the like
button the subscribe button and to ring
the notification bell if you don't i
won't drop into my jersey accent with
saying this line like i just did right
now you'll never get to hear it again i
won't talk like this ever but if you
guys want to see that let me know let me
down let me down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
background and it goes
okay